ich habe longkowitz ja das war ein
Schock vor einem halben Jahr nach einem
grippalen Infekt kann mich einfach nicht
mehr auf die Beine und das im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes seitdem habe ich jeden
Morgen also mache ich mit weichen Knien
auf und bin nicht mehr so leistungsfähig
wie sonst im Alltag merkt man es mir
nicht an aber so manche körperliche
Anstrengung und vor allem geistige die
ermüden mich total und da muss ich mich
dann tatsächlich danach ins Bett legen
und auch kognitiv habe ich manchmal
Ausfälle im Moment kann ich die Wohnung
nicht verlassen ohne mindestens einmal
wiederzukommen weil ich irgendetwas
vergessen habe ja deswegen war ich auch
hier kaum zu sehen und alle Projekte
liefen nur in Zeitlupe ab aber ich bin
damit ein wirklich harmloser Fall es
gibt Menschen die so erschöpft sind dass
sie gar nicht mehr aus dem Bett kommen
für die jeder ganz zur Toilette ein
Kraftakt ist und die in einer wirklich
schlimmen Verfassung sind bei mir tritt
das nur ab und zu auf und das ganze fing
ziemlich untypisch an ich hatte eine
Kurve im april 2021 und ab dann und das
scheint wirklich symptomatisch zu sein
hatte ich immer wieder so ganz seltsame
Infekte und zwar die sich in
Rückenschmerzen ausdrücken vor allem
dann manchmal kam Schnupfen Husten dazu
und im Sommer letzten Jahres da kam
ebenso ein Infekt ich hatte erst
Rückenschmerzen dann kam Husten und
Schnupfen und dann wurde ich richtig
krank und lag erstmal ja so zwei Wochen
im Bett und danach hatte ich die weichen
Knie ja und dann bin ich zum Arzt und
Stück für Stück kam dann raus ja das
muss wohl longkowitz sein und immer mal
wieder viel öfter als früher werde ich
jetzt krank und muss dann für Tage oder
Wochen ins Bett letztlich erst im
Dezember habe ich zwei Wochen war ich
wirklich krank wie im Koma ich konnte
nichts tun ich war so erschöpft dass
selbst wenn ich nicht geschlafen habe es
war mir nicht langweilig ich war einfach
vollkommen k.o ich konnte einfach nichts
tun ja manchmal auch ohne jede Erkältung
Symptome lässt sich fing es einfach ein
Minuten nach einer körperlichen
Anstrengung an und zwei Tage lang war
ich außer Gefecht und für viele ist das
dann eben ein Dauerzustand und ich
möchte für diese Leute die wirklich
darunter so sehr leiden mal eine Lanze
brechen das sind die vergessenen Helden
und Helden dieser Pandemie und es sind
eben keine Einzelfälle vor der Pandemie
litten rund 250.000 Menschen an diesem
chronischen Erschöpfungssyndrom jetzt
sind es 300.000 mehr und ein Viertel
davon liegt in abgedunkelten Räumen und
ist so gar nichts mehr in der Lage
myalgische enzephalo Myelitis
chronisches fatig-syndrom kurz mecfs
heißt die Krankheit in der Fachsprache
und durch die Pandemie mit ihren vielen
Fällen wird sie zum ersten Mal wirklich
anerkannt vorher wurde man gerne in die
Psychiatrie geschickt statt nach den
organischen Ursachen zu suchen das ist
jetzt Gott sei Dank anders zerweist die
Wissenschaft wegen dieses Jahrzehnte
lang Irrtums noch wenig über die
Erkrankung es ist wohl eben eine
Autoimmunerkrankung dafür sprechen
werden immer mehr Studien aber es geht
voran der Bundestag will über alle
Parteigrenzen hinweg für die Schaffung
von Behandlungszentren sorgen bundesweit
bisher gibt es zwei in Deutschland Fälle
wie meiner werden dort gar nicht erst
behandelt dafür ist einfach keine
Kapazität da Menschen die schlimmer
betroffen sind die haben Vortritt denn
so die Erfahrung nach sechs Monaten bis
zu einem Jahr wird es bei mir wohl
langsam besser werden das gilt für viele
Betroffene nicht wer sich also
informieren oder betroffen unterstützen
möchte findet mehr Infos bei nicht
genesen der Link zu der Initiative ist
hier
da da irgendwo hier im Bild bei Youtube
und in der Videobeschreibung demnächst
werde ich die Gruppe noch mal
ausführlicher vorstellen ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran